Microsoft as you may have heard is
planning a major announcement today
about the future of artificial
intelligence and only on CBS Morning CEO
Satya Nadella sat down with me ahead of
time to talk about the company's plans
and how they could affect your life and
your job
what do you say to people watching who
are worried that what you're building
might make the economy grow but will
disrupt their job and their life in ways
they cannot predict first of all it's a
great point and I think even there I
feel like if you what this does really
create the draft
but the draft has to be read by somebody
has to be edited by somebody approved by
somebody and net net you think it will
create more jobs than it will take I
believe it creates more I would call it
both satisfaction in current jobs and
net new jobs
a lot of people are scared he's saying
wages might go up as well think about
that it's a big claim we're going to
share more of our conversation on
Microsoft's big announcement which we
can't detail just yet but all of it's
coming up tomorrow on CBS mornings did
you say wages going up that's what
they're saying favor that's the claim